something I hate her just I just don't
talk to her
Jon Gosselin may not have much of a
relationship with his ex-wife Kate but
the dad of eight is still connected to
the city where they fell in love his
hometown Reading Pennsylvania I have
some good memories up here yeah the 39
year old gave et's Jennifer perros a
tour of special places from his past
including his childhood home I lived
here for 27 years Wow like pretty much
the entire first half of your life yep
we'd used to take our Easter picture
over who else is from this town Taylor
Swift yes Taylor Swift's hometown I
don't know her I'm a generation apart
maintain herself it's all sure your
daughter is that yeah love the fact that
from the same time you know next John
takes us to his high school what kind of
student were you in high school I was
okay okay I was a shot major actually
went to college for industrial
technology which is shot where'd you go
to college
what's a Millersville for a little bit
and then I meant to Europe and then I
came back met Kate and the rest is
history
part of that history John and Kate's
wedding day now we're at the location
where I got married which is when 1999
Wow 17 years ago yeah it's crazy crazy
so no the wedding receptions we had a
tent out front and we got married there
and then we had a reception out back but
the funny thing is the people that lived
here before we used to store all the
diapers for the babies in their basement
cuz we had no storage at our house that
house just two blocks away was John's
first home with Kate so this is the
house that you lived um in the show
first started yes
looking back knowing what was gonna come
do you think you would have done it uh
the experiences I've had on television
are astronomical the people I've met the
things I do now I would have changed a
little bit
maybe contractual it was but um I don't
regrets my kids are financially taken
care of and I mean I can't go back you
know I just couldn't learn
you